It's a tale as old as time,
a song as old as rhyme;
an enchantress turning an 11-year-old into a feral monster,
who 10 years later, traps a girl in a castle until she loves him.
You know! That old chesnut!
Welcome to this poor provincial French village,
where everyone has an American accent.
It's not right for a woman to read.
What's wrong with her?
She's crazy!
Marie! The baguette.
And meet Belle,
daughter of the local killing machine inventor.
Belle, look out!
Belle longs for adventure,
and she'll get just that when she's kidnapped by the Beast,
a Prince who's so bad at this job,
he's been missing for 10 years and no one seems to notice.
What is this place?
Watch romance bloom between her and Prince- ...
...uhhh, him.
They never do say his name, do they?
In this fairy tale that teaches every kid it's what's on the inside that counts,
but it doesn't hurt to be so rich you own a castle with its own library and some magic slaves.
Cheer, as this strong, smart, independent woman rejects this
violent,
controlling,
bad-mannered,
hairy dude,
who imprisons her dad,
for this
violent,
controlling,
bad-mannered,
hairy dude,
who imprisons her dad.
Wait, why does he lock up her dad?
The dude clearly wants to be left alone.
I'll give you a place to stay.
No!
Can't he just, you know,
let him leave and get eaten by wolves or something?
That seems a lot easier than feeding an old man for decades.
But Belle isn't alone,
she's trapped with dozens of living objects that raises dozens of uncomfortable questions like...
Did everything that moves used to be a person?
Like are all those plates people?
And what happened to all the actual stuff?
Did it merged with the servants?
Would they go to trial for murdering all those villagers?
That bureau straight up crushes that guy.
If the Beast were cursed,
why did all the servants get deformed too?
Man, this movie is messed up!
So be Disney's guest
at this tale as old as stockholm syndrome,
which was the first animated feature to be nominated for Best Picture,
but lost to a movie with a very similar plot;
You will, join me for dinner.
You rubs the motion on its skin, or else it gets the hose again.
and manage to distract us from its messed up story
with some of Disney's most beloved songs,
Like...
The 'I'm Too Good For This Place' song.
The 'Sucking Yourself Up' song.
The 'It Sucks To Work Here' song.
And, 'The Toxic Relationship' song.
Starring...
His moustache tickles, mama.
Ugh....
Do I still have to sleep in the cupboard?
Uhohoho...
Hahehahaha!
You have 20 brothers and sisters, so
yeah, you probably do.
Hey Screen Junkies,
want even more Disney magic?
Then be our guest and click the box on the left,
to watch our Honest Trailer for Moana.
Or click the box on the right to look into our enchanted mirror
as we rank every Disney Princess and find out who is the best of the best.
Don't be a Gaston, check it out now.